[Music]
what a what a what a what an
absolute what a what a l what a l what
an
[Music]
absolute ah what a lad well probably the
biggest piece of feedback I get on this
podcast is that I don't get enough
female Lads on the podcast because
there's plenty of great ones out there
so I've gone straight to one of the
all-time greats she started off as a
professional netballer with the Mystic
before being converted to rugby where
she instantly made an impact carving up
on the Rugby field with both the black
Ferns and the New Zealand seven side in
2013 she won the Rugby World Cup while
in that same year she was also named the
international women's sevens player of
the year she's also Olympic silver
medalist and most importantly she is the
mother to three beautiful girls and the
wife to the absolute lad Peter R ke she
is one of the alltime Great stok have on
it is Kayla a bonjour bonjour thank you
for having me no looking looking forward
to it I was um flicking through your um
podcast that you've set up obviously um
life on the sidelines podcast very cool
um setup that you've done there so if
you haven't tuned into that and you're
listening to that make sure you go
listen to that thank you Jimmy um how
did you how did you get involved into
that oh well you know a bit of a
language barrier living in France um and
one of the other wives J mil who's um
shifted over here a couple years ago a
lot younger uh than me and just yeah we
just spoke about it um
she's obviously had it as a wanted to do
it for a while and then she kind of
brought it up to me I said this was on a
Wednesday and then on the Friday went
around to her husband's house and well
their house me and Peter and uh had a
few wines and then we launched it live
on social open the door the boys are
like you're joking I said start res
sharing it and they're like we're not
sharing anything so yeah within um two
two days she came with an idea and on
the Friday we actioned it and um yeah
we've had a few guests on so far and
yeah just just this life I guess is
being over here having time on our hands
and can't work because of the Visas and
language barrier and it just gives us
something to do during the day and and
also nice to listen to other women on
the sidelines and hopefully it'll grow
something bigger in the months to come
and we Branch out a bit more so yeah
that's what we're doing at the moment or
what I'm doing yeah it's it's so cool
because it is such a um unique sort of
situation he obviously when when you're
in it you know it but um life on the
other side having to follow um your
man's journey and um move to wherever
they're moving and um pick up a
lifestyle wherever wherever you are for
um an unknown amount of time it's um
very unsettling and especially when
you've got kids it's um there's a lot to
it so I know there's so many um partners
of athletes who who can relate to some
of those stories that are shared yeah no
we've had some good ones so far and I
think I'm we to take something out of
everyone that we have on the guests um
both J and I have taken a lot away from
people um with experience husbands or
not and all around the world at the
moment Global so no it's exciting um
gives us something to do and it's nice
to hear someone else's story from the
sideline that's kind of in it with us to
an extent and um yeah hopefully we can
keep growing it so reach out to us
Wags yeah and I'm hoping to capture some
of that on this because you you've
obviously done it all you've been um the
star on the field and now the star off
it so I'm looking forward to hearing a
little bit more about your journey and
how you found that so um but we will get
to the start because obviously um you
come from a pretty um significant rugby
family um I'd imagine rugby was a huge
part of your upbringing yes yes yes just
sport in
general um but yeah dad my dad obviously
born and raised in Wata and Nei a little
little town in the Nei um both my mom
and my dad are from there so easy when
it came to family celebrations and
Christmases all in one one city um and
yeah he obviously was a rugby player a
league player or league and rugby and
then my mom was a netballer and
then yeah obviously he couldn't quite
crack it in New Zealand so went offshore
um with Union first and then that didn't
quite work in England and then he
switched a league um and the mom
obviously Luke's 5 years older than me
um and she said well I'm not having a
baby in England or a British baby so she
flew home had me then two months two
months old flew back to the England and
we lived there for seven seven eight
years um so my childhood memories
everything it's the UK oh true yeah ra
raised there as a little British kids
and then moved back in 96 so I think I
was like eight eight or nine so yeah my
primary school we moved to F pooa which
is the Hibiscus Coast north of Auckland
and primary intermediate and high school
down on the shore at west lake girls um
so yeah the I wasn't really introduced
to sport kind of you know from from a
young age age it was more like schooling
and the English way and it wasn't until
we moved back to New Zealand that you
know Luke and I both got stuck into the
Kiwi way of sport rugby in nit ball so
yeah interesting hey so how hard was
that move for you did you say you're 9
years old coming from an English a
proper English school to probably a
little bit more humble kiwi school would
imagine one of the one thing I I
remember is all the kids mocking my
accent and then asking mom and dad why
the kids were wearing no shoes why were
they bare feet barefoot yeah six months
we lost our accents and then um yeah
fulling swinging you know especially
going back home to the nackie and seeing
all the cousins and yeah bare feet when
it's freezing I was I don't get it um
especially when we're in the in the
English cold but yeah no it took about
six months get used to it and then
settled back in and haven't looked back
since but I have a lot of memories
growing up in England so being here now
is quite cool but full circle moment um
but yeah well sport a massive part of
your upbringing even in England like
were you you and Luke constantly yeah
playing against each other or yeah um I
guess back then probably not appropriate
now but we follow we went to every game
like Mom was a sport fanatic as well I
think which is quite cool probably how I
raised my children as well but um every
game like even sometime after matches in
clubs sometimes one would take us out
we'll be asleep under the under the Bars
Under the tables and clubs like
everyone's smoking and drinking everyone
stinks but like we were brought up and
raised around sport um every weekend
dadge trainings you know sometimes we go
to after school and then obviously Luke
actually played soccer um obviously in
England growing up that was his story so
he was a football player and I used to
watch him train and and yeah just annoy
the [__] out of him basically at home um
that annoying sister and he used to wind
me up too so he was 5 years older than
me so we've got like videos on VCRs back
in the day of him just annoying me and
rocking me up and in the lounge and
whatnot but yeah he was a soccer player
so between his soccer games and Dad's
League um yeah I've just been around it
from day dot on the sidelines I guess so
and then when did your netball start to
become pretty serious at primary school
so obviously mom pushed me into to nitb
uh and she was my actual coach at
primary for red Beach primary school so
yeah and then through the intermediate
um form one form two she was my coach um
and then shift off to high school which
was we lived on the coast which is like
about a 20 minute 25 minute from the
shore and basically Luke dad just chose
the best rugby school for him so not AA
College it was down at west lake and
then I pretty much followed What was the
best high school for netball or best
school um for me so to try and keep
pushing the netball scene um so yeah
joined up to West Lake as well and um
made top teams at high school and then
Dad actually got a coaching gig right in
the middle of my fifth form down at paly
for the for the mon two team so I
actually spent half of fifth half of
sixth form a whole of sixth form and
half a seventh form in py um and that
was a big shift especially in your
teenage years like you've got
established group of friends and Sport
my netball is going really well at North
Harbor my North Harbor netball age
groups um and then yeah I had to up and
leave with Mom and Dad to P me um but I
actually had a few friends through some
obviously nit ball and playing age
groups and meeting other girls and at
that time tutour which is now
um had a change but back then there was
12 girls 12 netballers um IET closing
jewelry school 12 netball girls and I
had the choice to either going there and
being in a proper netb high school or
going to paly girls um and Mars Gordon
who was a principal at the time and now
as Hamilton girls principal really like
one of my second mom she basically sat
Mom and Dad down was like look she can
go tutour and L nbor and do you know her
studies there but if she comes to py she
can do athletic she can do rugby she can
do hockey like and have a big variety of
friendship so I went down that Avenue
obviously mom and dad put me into py and
quite a small town so played touch um
with everyone and um couple of 15s rugby
games roped into a couple of games with
selika wiata back then um and obviously
my netball still continued there with
Weston in under 21s and then moved back
to ockland in seventh form went back to
West Lake finished off school there and
nit ball um up in North irelands and
then yeah and then kind of went into
adult like Prem npple grades um and like
I just Luke Luke my brother's just like
a we're just two different opposites
he's his training ethic is something
else I just went with through the
motions and just s my talent and just
like I was about social life my friends
you know he was the complete opposite
and so my dad really struggled with I
think the both of us well not struggled
but two different two different children
um and looking back if I had done what
he had done I would would have been a s
firm but I just yeah I just was too cool
go the movies hang out with mates and
just kind of made my way through age
groups and then didn't think i' be like
obviously the soul fans for Nick ball is
your dream that's your goal and you know
it's this pretty Cutthroat and not
political but you kind of know if you're
going to make it and you know if you're
not um so then A&Z came about and
obviously I used to work as a caterer at
some of the force games when it was
called NPC and used to just love seeing
it and then that was my goal and then it
shift to a andz which was with the
Aussie girls um so that was kind of a
goal and then yeah was a training
partner in 2010 I think it was um and
then 2011 became a full contracted
member for one one
season I sat behind the world's best
player which you know I'm totally
content with Tim poter um and I got four
minutes on the court on the whole season
when we were up by 20 goals against the
tactics so but for me like I was a
stoked to be around all those girls like
Ria cat like just yeah I was like okay
sh I actually have to work hard and
actually put on the effort and and train
harder and
and whatnot so and then yeah that's was
2011 and we actually made it to the
final the Grand Final over in Brisbane
in Queensland which was yeah unreal
experience I guess you know I didn't get
on the court but I trained every day
with them it was semi-professional back
then um are you on the bench ready to go
on in these games or do they name a
bench yeah so all these games you're
ready yeah no like it's 12 yeah I warm
up I stood on the bench and then I do
the duty dirties afterwards and do
running behind the stadium when they're
upstairs doing promos yeah for literally
a whole season um but I was happy like I
still worked um in an Edmund job and
then i' go do that as well like I just
stoked to be around all like they were
it was pretty stacked team back then in
2011 for the mystics um and made the
Grand Final and lost to the Firebirds
but you know I got got a trip over there
and we go to Aussie and do trips and
stuff which was pretty cool but yeah I'm
looking back now and then the following
year I thought okay cool this is my shot
because Tim P's retiring like um Jenny
May's gone and then I got dropped so I
was like oh this is
awkward so it was between actually
Porsche and I me Porsha and Bailey M um
and Debbie Fuller at the time just kind
of decided to go for a different
positional difference and Porsche was a
center Wing d i was a center wing attack
and yeah so they took Porche and then
dropped me were you playing well did you
felt like did you feel like you deserved
um to be dropped or well yeah because I
worked my ass off for a whole season I
didn't complain once I you know
you know I'm I'm I'm like a team person
so I would never be not selfish at all
like i' always put the team first I just
love being in the environment you know
just being rubbing shoulders with the
with the country's best probably world's
best players too so I just knew my place
knew my but I thought that 2012 years
okay ra I've done my hard yard I might
get a shot with a couple game and then
positional wise it just didn't happen
that year and so um yeah I got off of
the training partner role but I was I've
already done that I've I've had a taste
I'm all going backwards so I was like
how I'm I going to do and literally
within like I think was like two weeks
nzu came out with a go for gold campaign
for seven because now it was an Olympic
sport so literally was like I think two
or three weeks later dad sent me the the
link to the website and I was like H H
yeah his dream is me to be to be a rugby
player yeah and I'm like no Mom and I
are like no nitb nitb nitb and he's just
like um but growing up I didn't I didn't
watch much of the 15s of black F oh New
Zealand the 15s back then I was because
I was Nall um and knew Anna Richards I
knew you know it's far I knew certain
women but I didn't follow them I didn't
watch the games or World Cups I I would
watch World Cups and that's how I first
saw
Klapper um but yeah I was like oh are
you sure like read up to it and I
actually we were still kind of doing
Club Nick at the time and Porche and I
were in the same club for
mags um and obviously now she's got this
full contract for mys I've been dropped
both of us have dared to like you need
to go to this trial and give it a crack
so we both cuz I hadn't saiden nous six
training she was obviously said yes and
We snuck out one night it was at 6:00
down at um uni Tech and it was a trial
night um so her and I kind of snuck off
she's fully contracted I'm kind of in
between and went to this trial night
just tickled some tickle bags did some
Sprints running I think a fitness test
um which obviously netballers rocked up
in our tights because netballers were
like long tights and everyone's giving
us filthy looks I'm like this is we are
not filling in here um but with a lot of
rugby and and also some other people
that like hockey played like not just
rugby um because it was a campaign for
Just Sports women in general um but
obviously there's a lot of rugby girls
there and we just yeah that night I
still remember and then Alan bunting was
the assistant coach but he was running
that night in ockland and yeah he called
me in Porsche side and took our names
down and can't really remember what
happened there next minute we made a
team that went to
fij Oceania tournament
and yeah never and then that happened
and then then she had to make the
decision obviously what she was going to
do I was like I'm cracking into the
sevens on we were not contracted there
was no money involved it was purely just
um part-time at that point and it was
all regional and did you know you were
going to be good did you did you feel
like you were better than the others N I
was not you should see I'm the The Rock
area is obviously coming I for netball
and being a non-c contct sport I was
known for like hip throwing and quite
physical on the court um so I didn't
have any worry about contact but it was
was just the the rck area where I used
even watching like men's rugby I'm like
oh I just would not put my head in that
kind of space but with sevens I was like
oh you know I haven't really seen I've
watched Men sevens you know watching DJ
and all the men sevens a lot more than I
have um the woman's side of the game so
I've seen seven tournaments online so
yeah I was like I let's give it a crack
and then but there was quite a lot of
there was some hierarchy at the time
like hurana Manuel Linda T Carlo and all
the big big rugby girls and we kind of
just came in and they were were real
welcoming like I think um they'd
obviously be behind the scenes pushing
this for this for years um with the NZ
to get this on thepit committee and you
know they sevens is different to 15s um
in terms of the game and the speed and
whatnot so they were adant looking for
athletes as well as rugby players for
the for the knowledge of the game
but yeah I kind of thought I knew even
about rugby um after watching it for how
many years and so I did learn a few
things pretty quickly
um yeah my first tournament was in Fiji
in 20 2012 with the girls in August and
Ruby Tu was my roomy and uh Hazel tubic
two very hundy girls um Hazel's like
lived and bred rugby and Ruby's just
hundies so I was like oh this is awesome
and yeah like just a whole different
scene and um yeah obviously Fiji is
amazing beautiful country and yeah we
won that tournament B Aussie and I think
I have I had no idea about um I did know
about the black Jersey and what it meant
and how you know obviously New Zealand
Rugby's life um and it's massive at home
and Global globally too so but I didn't
know how deep it kind of was um to some
of the older girls and the girls that
have been around the been around the
game for a long time so us newbies they
had to you know kind of get us involved
in that and talk about the history of
the game and the jersey and the women
before us and but also we were a Pioneer
to a new Legacy the sevens was you know
they've had a sevens team before that's
gone to the World Cup but it was never
funded they were never paid they went
there on their back so
this is a different kind of um scenario
so we will also there is history in it
but also a new new Legacy as well so
hurana and Linda they kind of those
older girls made that really special um
so it was really cool to be a part of
now looking back that we were the
Pioneers to this sevens campaign that's
still going now pretty strong so but the
big one for me was I still was like oh
yeah that was really cool um it was
still a bit Gumby bit a bit chubby on
the side and had a a good tournament and
then it was Dubai was the the World
Series the first leg of the HSBC back
then and I was like well this is pretty
serious that's pretty cool like we get
to go to Dubai like we going to go to
Australia for net ball and I was like
[__] like okay and because I was still
quite new the management everyone like
no one really knew where the game was
going or what where the where the team
was going it was all really new really
new and so they just had a bunch of
girls and they pick from and then they
take us so went to Dubai
um yeah that was that was nuts and then
we won that tournament and I remember
walking around stadium with porsa and a
couple other girls at the end and just
cuz we alongside the men obviously that
series um and we played before the men's
final so our final we bit Aussie aie
some yeah I think it was aie then we
walked around the crowd and did like a
lap and I was just like this is so like
cool but also uncomfortable because we
don't know what we're doing we're like
waving to the crowd and then I just
remember one corner was like the Kenyan
fans that were just going crazy in the
crowd I was like this is like a party I
like what even is this and then that's
when I looked at Porsche and I was like
I'm St with us so I'm not going back to
new pool and she kind of looked and was
like [__] this is unreal like so she had
a big decision I kind of was like I'm My
Mind Set like I'm G to going to roll
with this and give it a good crack and
yeah it just flowed on from there just
got bigger and bigger and the
tournaments the world rugby the other
nations we were well ahead of everyone
um you know in terms of skill set just
and just the game uh the knowledge of
the game but now obviously it's pretty
on par with every nations with resources
and two two Olympic Cycles but but yeah
like at the start it was Olympic Olympic
sport and that's why I chose to convert
but also like well netball is not happen
for me the door's shut it's not sh I can
go back but I'm like I've I'm 24 now 25
like you kind of know if you're going to
be a silver Fern at 25 or not like so I
was like that's gone like I'm not going
to be a soul Fern and so this kind of
popped up and yeah in 2013 it kind of
got quite serious and we were on you
know four World Series tournaments and
it's grow and grow and grew and then
obviously yeah ups and downs on those
four years and then I obviously met
Peter in 2013 um and a very famous club
Out West Oakland Hangar bar oh no doubt
so obviously I was quite full on with
work and training and I had no you know
like we'd have also we were quite quite
a little party group back then us girls
um would have Sunday sessions and and
because we weren't fully contracted so
how did the contracts work oh um I don't
even so 2012 13 into 14 or 15 yeah like
we'd been speaking about it but the big
thing was centralization you'd have to
actually to make to make us full time
you have to centralize us and so not not
at that time women girls didn't want to
move cuz we still had jobs because we
had to have a job didn't want to move
unless you could pay us full full time
was that the same for you with netball
and ragby both of them were only sort of
part time you still had to have a job
yeah unless you're a silver F because
you also got a silver F salary as well
as the MS I was just Ms and to have a
yeah a lot of girls studied but I was
out I I work so but yeah that was
another reason another cool thing to be
a part of and making sure that was all
um but at that time none of us paid like
played for that I had a full-time job
still and could go to trainings before
work and after work and you know I had a
pretty good employee so an understanding
and the girls a lot of girls studied so
and we weren't there for the money we
knew that was never going to come unless
we you know that was going to happen
down the track but in 2012 13 14 we just
had to keep winning keep growing the
game and then the N I would deal with
that when it comes to push comes to
shove and obviously after the Olympics
so yeah I think after the Olympics was
when they centralized fulltime and
decided it was time to new cycle a lot
of us were kind of finished and then
they yeah made a centralization in the
mount mount monoi so yeah but I met
Peter in 2013 um at a bar didn't know
who he was um I know his friends I I
haven't seen you around round before and
then he Lally like oh yeah I play rugby
CH I was like yeah yeah whatever and
then um kind of Tex me he kind of said
oh yeah I'm going down to the mountain
next week I've got a tri for the sevens
like you play sevens and he's like yeah
I'm going down for the World Cup Russia
trial for sevens and I'm like oh no
because he was playing Harbor at the
time itm and I said oh I I am too
because I play sens 2 kind of thing and
it was just real weird and I remember
Googling him being like he's only 20
years old and I was
24 like he looked way older at the time
I was thought you did not just turned 21
I was 24 and then yeah and then a couple
weeks later we're just chatting and then
he ended up at the mount and the out and
we're having like yeah World Cup Russia
trials for 2013 and he went for the
men's and I was going for the girls and
yeah and then he made the team um I made
the team but we're kind of still just
getting to know each other and then
we're in Russia together um they won we
won um number one alcohol in Russia's
vulka so yeah um and then came home
celebrated and yeah pretty much made it
official together yeah in end of 2013
how that fell love in Russia Yeah well
yeah I just I had my doubt like rugby
players to me I'm kind like look I'm
just it's just not going to work like
we're both I just didn't see it it was
going to be quite tough and but then you
can't can't help who you fall in love
with so I was like okay well and he was
doing really well like he was up and
coming he was playing itm um you know
New Zealand Sevens and then obviously
supers he was with the blues wider at
the time which I was like he'll get a
blues full contract so yeah then it kind
of happened in 2014 he went to the com
games as well and I was just like it's
crazy so we made it work um with my
traveling and yeah and then obviously
kind of support each other a lot through
it all and then
um yeah kind of an honeymoon phase i'
call it but everything was all going
well because we were living in ockland
he was doing Blues I was I was at the
Millennium training on the shore and
everything worked out we lived together
because Dad's like live it move together
now and find out quick if you can get
along or not like go live together go go
move in together so I was like the hell
dead so he was like moving together see
if you know don't [__] around and don't
waste time so and then yeah we did
um and yeah back in 2014 and then he had
a really good season for the blues back
then that one season and um with JK the
coach and
then yeah kind of I think he got a pro
yeah obviously the Hurricanes came
knocking in 2015 um because the blues
were just coaching didn't know what was
happening there and then he signed with
the Hurricanes for two years which
didn't really affect me because then I
just moved to Wellington and then I just
regionally jumped to Wellington cuz we
still at that time all
regions they had resources down there
because there was three other Wellington
girls k f Simpkins Amanda Rash um so we
I just jumped in with them they've got a
high performance center there on the
waterfront of mamar so I just nothing
phased me and I still was traveling with
the team and I was doing my training
outside of there so that actually worked
well as as well
so um so all was going well and then
yeah did Rio and um how was Rio how was
it oh it was awesome um yeah was it was
nuts I don't even even know how to
explain like like obviously there was It
was kind of [__] in terms of like the
the the facilities and there cuz things
went finish and we were the Village New
Zealand's Village was at the end of the
whole place by the transport so like
they all the flash ones apartments at
the top was USA and then they kind of
got like less and less and less like no
windows no Plumbing so we were like in
that but we're close to the transport
station so but nothing phased us our
team had been through every up down
everything in between and women we just
got on with it so but like just yeah see
being amongst athletes and obviously the
first couple of days we were just trying
to find famous people and then we're
taking photos of like I remember some
Jamaican chicks and the eating the food
horn I was like I don't know who they
are but they're obviously famous so
we'll just grab a photo of them I like
they're probably sprinters so we had a
photo of these random chicks they're
just workers and then they have this
thing yeah um where you have the pen you
have a pen and like a Olympic thing is
you try and swap badges or pins with
people um oh yeah and that's kind of
what everyone kind of does and
yeah I think I I think it was um I think
it was Venus and we went up to her and I
finally got my moment I was um yeah we
Tred to find Serena and Venus the whole
time because I was like I'm just idols
and she on her Instagram or might have
been Snapchat or something said she was
at the park and it was just up in the
middle of our thing so we all raced
there and she was gone so we missed her
F and then the other girl saw her at
dinner time and got photos of and I
missed that and then Venus was walking
out of the food court and I was like
this is my one shot I'm was going to do
it went up to her and I literally looked
at her I was like do you want to stop
badging she like I already have a New
Zealand
one oh my God I'm so embarrassed but I
was like hey I had a conversation with
her I said you want to swap Badges and
she I've already got one so I was like
oh but just being around like
yeah get it yeah yeah she looked at me
she spoke to me we had dialogue but she
didn't I didn't get her badge her pen
but um and and then obviously with the
whole New Zealand team as well um
because we were in so much in our own
nit with women men's and women sevens um
being a part of a bigger team and group
that was pretty special um you know
being around Valerie who we we obviously
trained with her up in Oakland but just
being around her and her tournament mode
and all the other athletes the rowers
and just the clubhouse and what the New
Zealand team does and how culture like
every welcoming to be a PO or hucker and
other teams will come out of their
apartments and just watch like um yeah
just want to see every country does
things differently and for me that was
probably the biggest thing was being in
a bigger team in other sports and and
couldn't wait for our once our event was
over and we' finished to go and watch
the other athletes so we actually went
and watched Luca um with her canoeing
which I have never watched prior to the
Olympics and went and watched her live
and she won a medal and I was just like
yeah I think afterwards obviously the
Olympics and once our focus and our job
was done I couldn't wait to go watch the
other athletes and support them like
they were all supporting us but yeah it
just the food caught the food like
everything what people say is real it
just was nuts um an experience that I've
just yeah very lucky and privileged to
being a part of and then yeah what do
you remember about your final obviously
you didn't quite get the gold that you
probably were dreaming of but a silver
medal what do you remember about that
game yeah no I thought um we did like we
were building every game um obviously it
was two games a day so obviously kind of
levels out the playing field a bit more
only having two and it was obviously
dragged on a bit more but it was for me
it was a it was a 20 minute final back
then um and that used to piss me off
because we yeah different training
regimes different trainer at the time um
but I don't think we're as fit as we
could have been and I knew that
obviously it it does make a difference a
10 minute half compared to seven
especially when you're playing all the
other five games at 14 minutes and you
jump to a final and it's the last game
and you're playing 20 which is usually
like 22 minutes um yeah that for me was
like oh this is it's a it's a massive
Game Changer so literally after R they
took that out and made it s minutes the
final which broke me but I think if it
had been 14 it would have been a
different story but in saying that um we
yeah we tried we got yeah just wasn't
meant to be that night and Aussie just
came out firing and um yeah pretty
guttering um but in saying that I was I
was proud I was like um we've just won a
middle which didn't probably took about
two years to sink in um we came home did
all the C tree around the country and
and all that that stuff but as a player
it's like yeah silver but I was like
could have been a gold and it wasn't
until some I think know who told me or
someone said to me like there's 10
11,000 athletes and some people don't
even get on the podium at all so it
might even be valve someone just said
like look girls it's it's a massive
you're on the tally chart and you've got
a medal which some yeah athletes go and
they prep for four years eight years
heaps of years and they don't even get
on the podium like um so when that was
said I kind like okay be be grateful now
Kayla like you've got a silver midle
something to be proud of um but yeah
still I have not actually watched the
game I've never watched that final back
ever um never watched it I've tried to
not so um yeah and then obviously I had
a burning desire obviously had to move
off offshore from New Zealand and how
hard was that for you cuz that's a
that's obviously a huge commitment when
you're in your Prime you've just come
off an Olympic game and now you've got
to um sort of step down well decid to
have a baby first decided to be a mom
so I had proba like Peter and I always
spoke about kids and my goal was Rio and
then he said well what happens after Rio
you know there's another four years
before the next Olympics um but two
years for com games which was in first
com games um post Olympics uh in 2017 so
I him and I and our families all kind of
spoke and I said look well I've done the
Pinnacle event I've took my big box I've
worked my ass off for four years I've
done it I've got a silver let's try for
a family and if it comes you know
quicker than I expected great then I can
try and make it back but that was
another whole
um another whole killer fish cuz um I'm
not the fittest person all my girls
around me that know me R players know me
that I wasn't the fastest Bronco I
wasn't I end up singles yes but
continuous maybe not um so like for for
me um and in the gym I'm not really a
big gym kind of person but I'll just
know tick boxes and do the gym because
the trainer wants you to do the gym and
do weights um because I had like a thing
about looking big I always had this body
image about I guess probably dating
Peter didn't really help I didn't want
to be seeing like oh he does this rugby
there's just a stigma around masculinity
and just looking big and I just I just
didn't want to yeah something was on my
head about that so I just didn't want to
look like that and so I used to be like
I don't want to do weights I don't look
heavy and the trainers would be like oh
my gosh like it's for the game I'm like
I'm fine I'm fine I can play I don't
need to lift big weights like I need to
get faster and fitter and so I was
always having constant battles with our
trainers being like I want to be faster
and fitter and they were like you need
to be stronger and F like just yeah so
that was a headache for four years but
um yeah so post 2016 me p and I decided
that we'd you know try and have a baby
and then literally happened pretty
quickly after Rio how supported are you
in that decision like um have you got
pressure from coaches have you like
obviously your coaches probably want you
to stay playing for them but how yeah
how supported are you on that well Shan
haran who was a coach at the time left
um and Ellen bunting the assistant coach
um I actually had a conversation with
him because he was his next stepping
like he obviously went up into um to the
head coach and I I just just had a
conversation with him said look like
I've I want to be a mom I'm 28 now like
I'm getting older and if I'm going to
try and come back for the next cycle um
I need to kind of move quickly now and
get back in time because or who knows
who knows and he said yeah go he he gave
me his full support he's you know he's
an awesome awesome guy obviously you can
tell now the Way's still still in there
and and making massive changes in the
woman's game but it was as him and I had
a conversation I had his full support
that's all I needed because he's a
national coach um provincials provinal
and that chops and changes but he was
like totally go for K like um and pretty
much supported me along the way but the
bigger
thing there was that we obviously had
contracts in place and memorandums what
they call them back then not quite a
full contract but there was no Clause
whatsoever for maternity leave or even
how to deal with pregnancy oh wow um so
I was like okay um so Rob nickel and I
are best friends um so for me I fell
pregnant straight away like literally
within two months I think it was
straight away which was cool um so that
happened and um yeah I had a lot of
meetings with the New Zealand player
association um because it was a whole
new territory for
nzr um and nzr paa obviously knit ball
hats a clause and hockey players have a
clause but there was nothing for the
female side in rugby so it was new
territory which I'm quite cool to be a
part of and be a part of something new
and and help with sorting that all out
and pinning that to paper and and um
being a part of that which is really
special and then um and saying that it
also
drove me to try and come back quicker
after having I don't know my pregnancy I
was OCD I was walking every day I was
like I'm coming straight back after I've
had her I'm coming straight back into
the environment um I was yeah really
like I'm coming back just try and prove
a point and also lay a foundation for
other women um in New Zealand and
globally that you can have a baby and
come back cuz no one's done it so no one
had ever done that before no one had had
a baby not in the sevens wow okay 15s
yes um cuz Pungo Rene wi Cliff um was
the first person you know she had a baby
was back running in 6 weeks um to one of
our camps um so yeah Renee W Cliff is
the only one I know personally in New
Zealand um and obviously this KLA ho
hipper and and other woman but I think
fully contracted because in 2017 we were
fully contracted now and it's fulltime
so you um you know those we didn't have
contracts but then was kind of like well
n could be like come back when you you
know got to proove yourself like yeah so
yeah I had her really good pregnancy uh
went quickly think was good birth was
great great Midwife in Wellington and I
remember she was a really chill baby
like couldn't have asked for any bit she
slept I had to wake her to feed her she
sleep she was just amazing baby never
cried so I was like okay well this was
all new to me so I was like okay called
buce and I was like okay well she's
three months old now he's like well well
chill and I was like no no she's three
months old life's great I want to get
back into it and in that um Peter
obviously supers as Wellington but itm
was North Harbor but then he signed with
wour so we actually to move up to
Hamilton live with um our family friend
Mars Gordon at her house and I went back
to the back training she was three
months old um which meant that I got
paid again because for me I was like I
don't have no income I had them
maternity to leave from the government
which was awesome and obviously that was
quite cool that was all R in the plan um
but for me I was like I want to get back
and training and get my pay again so
yeah I did that jumped in with the girls
in Hamilton and um sat back training
with a goal to go to Australia in a uh I
think she would have been four months so
we went to Australia when she was four
months old I didn't play in the
tournament but just got you know back to
running with Brad Anderson who is unreal
like another reason why I came back and
was so comfortable because he's you know
Tiana now with his wife's you know they
had a baby and he's he's just an awesome
guy really you know about the athlete so
he helped me and it was a new territory
for a few people and just you know
treated it with with caution but also
was I know my body fine yeah um so no
one really knew what happened but um
first error was I came back in Hamilton
and it was Mas which was high intensity
max
speed and I was still breastfeeding at
this because I was like I really know
what's happening and no one really knew
and I had really know advice and I
remember doing sprints mas and then that
afternoon I couldn't walk my ankles were
just like seizing I was like what the
[__] is happening so I remember ringing
the physio like I don't know what's
happening my ankles are like all yeah
blocked up and just in then we found out
through um research that um when you are
breastfeeding you have relaxed muscles
and so my not supp be having so
literally that afternoon off off the
boob sell on the bottle that night and
she was straight on the bottle took it
like a champ NOS she was there so yeah
little things like that were learning
along the way and obviously feeding that
back to the you know to the sevens admin
and feedback and so yeah and then Aussie
she was 4 months old and then my B goal
was du by 2017 back on the world circuit
after to having a baby um and I pushed
know wh my house up with the help of the
girls around me the team the management
were unreal Peter my family um and with
this going on Peter also had no supers
contract for
2017 so obviously the the teams are
announced around October September
October now October November so what us
all happening in me returning back and
doing my thing my mate on the side
didn't know what was happening in his
rugby um oh calm down so we unknown for
him but for me I was like you know I've
got my goal I'm going back in I'm going
to make make a statement and and you
know and get back out there with Stella
alongside me which is just my goal my
dream where he was struggling playing
for w coutour no super contract didn't
know what was going to happen and was
like oh [__] um okay look I'll go to
Dubai I'll try and make that team and I
did so in December she was eight months
old flew business to Dubai here is
Stellar 8mth old in business class
living her best life um
obviously part of the agreement with NZ
RPA and nzu was the support help so my
mom they have a support Personnel until
the baby's won so Mom got to fly over
yeah fly over and it was all funded with
nzr paa and nzr um in terms of player
pool payment and they figured that all
out financially and yeah until the B you
know there's a WR in there now until the
baby's one you can have a support person
at all times and camps travel and may
have changed now but so Mom flew over
and got to come and experience that and
saying that JW Mar at 20 to um living
our best lives in Dubai but we had a
week obviously in Abu Dhabi which um
John looks after us over there the team
off his back and so we had a week in Abu
Dhabi she was you know living a best
life and then we came across a Dubai and
played that tournament and yeah I made
it back on the field um we obviously
dropped out short on the quarters and
lost um to USA but for me it was a
bigger picture and I actually had other
nations talking so I had a couple of the
aussy girls come to me shaie um and
Shannon Perry asking me about you know
what's written in the in the contracts
cuz they're going through that at the
moment and girls W to have babies and um
the Fijian girls are just like coming
and grabbing Stella and taking her off
and yeah had a lot of talk was happening
around the actual Nations and who's
who's paying for her mom who's paying
for the baby like a lot of talk was
happening which is what I it's good talk
so that was all happening which is quite
cool and yes I hope I kind of helped um
hopefully helped with that situation um
and other unions about helping out women
and babies and so yeah got made it back
to Dubai stell's on the sidelines um
staff um girls really welcoming cool
having her on tour CU she was so chilled
and then while this was happening Peter
was you know got no contract but got a
gig in conic in Ireland where Bundy
Bundy and um Bundy and Kayla are are key
so there was a big pull draw card for
Peter like Bundy's there and they're set
up and um I'm just going to go as a
medical Joker for conic uh because uh
what's his name the coach Karen Kane was
it yes yeah Kane he was a coach and
obviously knew Peter from age groups and
stuff so he actually was over there
while I'm still doing the Sev so he went
up in October was playing for conic um
as a medical Joker so you're not really
don't know what's happening um and so
was that look yeah did Dubai was on high
as life like yeah next year's com games
2017's com games um and obviously we had
a wedding as well in the middle of all
that in the December the next month in
2017 got married he flew back back the
team released him we got married and
then he just pretty much we just decided
that um he's I can't do this without you
and Stella just he's just a family man
and needs his girls so yeah wasn't yeah
was kind of just again got to spoke with
buns I said look this is situation
Peter's you know the bread earner it's
his you know his career and I'm a mom
and a wife and now you know that's his
daughter so I want to go over there and
support him get him settled until he
knows what's happening long term like in
terms of Contracting cuz we I know
what's happening he's got to play he's
like full support way you go that was
really tough cuz especially for my
family cuz that meant I missed out on
the com games uh that following
following year and that was a tough one
to pill to swallow but I'm like for me
i' done everything it sucked but I'm
like I have a child and a husband and
going to go support him so I at the time
I was like oh it is what it is um
actually got a wedding present from
Conor to go to the Ashford castle and
for a honeymoon and I end up watching
the girls win the com games from a
lavish castle in Ireland so I was like
could be worse crying on the bed being
like could be there but this is pretty
special and um yeah and then the conic
kind of didn't really Venture away um
may obviously moved there gway english-
speaking gway awesome city um cool bunch
of girls I actually Bundy coached a
women's team there gogian and he's like
okay sis if we're going to if you're
going to come live with us for a month I
need you to come and you know play for
This Woman's team and I was like no I'm
I've just had a baby and I need to just
chill out know I go down and go to
trainings and he's not even there so 6
o00 and bearing in mind I don't play 15s
so and I play a summer s of summer so
I'm like okay I'm going to go jump in
this training with Irish a bunch of
Irish girls 6 pm. in the middle of
winter December I was like I don't know
what to wear cuz you know seven we just
wear shorts and I remember going to the
first training store staying at the
conic hotel next door to the fields and
I come home and I had like Ruth I think
her name is Ruth one of the English
Irish
props cut
prop like a bit fishy with me because I
like oh like oh this New Zealand woman
stons players coming to our training I
was like I don't play 15 like it's not
me like don't even say anything don't
even mention that because I don't I
don't play 15th so I got into the
Peter's at home with Stella after his
training six or eight and basically she
picked up the ball and ran straight at
me and just ran straight over me I was
just like I was like [__] you okay let's
go and then I was like oh then I got
angry because of people that know me I
get angry and so I was just like oh and
she did it again it was like a little
four a little four square drill two on
one yeah yeah yeah and she just was
wasn't even she just was like just
running at me I was like [__] so I had
to tackle this I do not tackle big mom
like I was she was a big girl prop for
Ireland Ruth yeah and then the second
time she did that and I just went I was
I don't know what I'm closed my eyes
tackled her and then she's
like and that was got to respect and so
I was like gone back I was crying on the
shower I was like I had freaking mud
everywhere I was like what are you
makeing [__] you Bundy like and but from
that night on the girls like it just it
made me it kind of yeah helped me get
over the fact that I was missing all my
girls back here in New Zealand and
playing with the sevens and this is the
best I'm going to get in terms of making
new friends and a new this could be our
new team we don't know so I just you
know try to jump into Community rugby
and cool bunch of girls played a few
games and obviously C no was from had a
few years there and she was up in Dublin
out at the time it was giving me [__] so
yeah a lot of kywi are in Ireland too so
that was quite cool and then obviously
Peter didn't didn't get Rec
contracted and then he played a game
against uh because obviously they have
the the two competitions and he had a
Euro game against too um and next minute
we're like [__] with you know we're
going back to New Zealand I'll go back
to the sevens and he didn't know where
his rugby career was at literally like
it was just it was devastating because
he pretty much he couldn't even make the
50 you have the super squads and then
you have the 50 wider Squad he couldn't
even make that in that November and I
just was like he was like what 20 23 20
like I think the Hurricanes just he just
didn't play in two years he had play
like maybe a couple minutes because he
had shoulder shoulder like just [__]
niggles just then he chose the sevens
and then touched him and pick him for
the Olympics that's another whole story
um when him and Kurt should have been
there so that was another that was a
[__] up and just he was in a real real R
just nothing's happening and he's yeah
it was pretty sad and and then all of a
sudden my brother gets a message from
Hugo M which was a too head
true um you know we've heard that Peter
is your brother-in-law um what's the
situation with him at kuk we've seen him
play and so literally it was like a
message to Luke and Luke messages us and
I'm like I obviously know the French
rugby and how it works with Luke but
Peter had no idea um and at this stage
he's got nothing oh we're going back to
New Zealand I'm going back to sevens um
and well like oh so we didn't so there
was just talks back and forth back and
forth conic was finished um done so we
went back back to New Zealand um in I
think it was May end of May the season
was and still talking back and forth
with the agents with
too and yeah got a two-year deal to
loose in 20 for 2018 June thanks L which
was just yeah which was nuts because he
had just that was his he was in clemont
obviously he's you know played in tus
and won a championship top 14 with tus
and he was up in clemont at the time and
that was his last year so he actually
had a house in too he's like well I'm
I'm retiring and finishing here so oh
hang out with you guys for a bit and get
you guys sorted and plant your feet and
it just it just spun around so quickly
to like we come home didn't know what
was happening we had Stella's first
birthday in May didn't telling family we
didn't know what we're doing and then
boom next minute we're flying in two
weeks we're flying to too and Peter
starting in June yeah how stressful and
unsettling is all that for you yeah it
was just like yeah well at the time I
was like oh this is yeah it was all over
the show um but I was pregnant at the
time so I had was pregnant with our
second child so was this another
decision you had to to make cuz
obviously you're still thinking you were
still talking about potentially coming
back to New Zealand and playing yeah
well I got pregnant and and that Fib so
when we're in CL I fell pregnant with a
sick one so I was like well Rugby's off
the books for 12 months for me so um so
for me I was like [__] well we didn't
know what we're doing so when the too
came out we're like we're going we're
going um and there's another whole story
and there got here in June um he'
obviously come over from kuk and had
like a medical done when he was playing
for kuk um snuck over um from Ireland
did US did his medical
here um yeah so that was another whole
story and then they signed him and then
when we um kind of had a bit of an issue
because when he did his medical he
missed his first his connecting flight
from Germany to to loose and that was a
day you were supposed to go to the
hospital and get the actual scans and
everything done on your body um but
because he was playing rugby they're
like oh you must be fine everything's
good sign the
contract and then on the Friday when he
finished they were like oh we've seen
your scans and we've we don't really
like what's happening with some parts of
your body um we don't really want
you it was just like roller we've gone
from in one week going to to to then our
agent being like oh [__] they've um
decided to just do a reverse on you how
did he reverse the reversal um our
agenty well they they've signed the
document you've signed the documents so
by court of law you are going to too and
you you're going oh wow so they
basically cut the contract in half the
salary in half and gave him one
year so we're like well we've got
nothing else um Luke's house is there
Luke's there like let's just go and give
it a shot so we came over in the June um
uh for Peter for me this is why I get
really emotional on where he's looking
back on when he came so bearing in mind
he's had nothing not wanted um did his
did his gig and conic playing really
well but not wanted there because he
wasn't the future so they didn't play
him as long alongside Bundy another
drama um idiot so yeah got to
too oh June jly August September no one
really spoke to him in terms of the
management he wasn't
playing um I'm pregnant at the time and
I'm trying to just feel it look it's
summer like just just you know just and
basically there's an esas team so it's
like their Academy um underneath the
pros so he's a top 14 contracted player
and paid but they weren't playing him
because
just those ones emotion like you know we
didn't want you but now you're here
because you have to be here because
legally so he literally had cold
shoulders he but my cousin was also here
Jared po my first cousin as well which
is another cool thing having him here um
and he was esas because he's a lot
younger and so basically Peter being
Peter and me being me and our family
being like [__] you need to play rugby
because we knew when six nations came
and half of that backline for T were all
going to be off to France that's when
he'd get a shot to prove himself so um
for me
luckily being in the New Zealand
environment and having mentalists and
coping mechanisms about dealing with
just [__] and just being down that was
probably the the big thing for me was
turning from um player athlete mode to
being a supportive wife and trying to
help him through one of the most you
know he had a contract we were getting
paid monthly but he wasn't playing
weekly so he was training his ass off
Monday to Friday and then not
playing and it happened and then this
obviously this esas is under 25s I think
but you can have dis session for two
players older like usually like Dupont
for example after his first ACL he came
back and played an SP game before he
went back to the pros so it's kind of
used as a game like a stepping stone
yeah Gateway but Peter yeah so Peter
turned around to the club was like well
if you're not going to play me I didn't
to play rugby I'm G to play isas and
they were like who like uh it's just not
a good look um because you're a pro and
we don't really want that and he turned
around and I was like we both were like
give [__] like he's he's playing he
needs to play he needs he needs match
Fitness because we know that come I
think it was around November October
November when the Six Nations kicks on
he he's going to get a shot so he did
that and credit to him he would go train
with the pros and then he'd turn up to
weekends and play what I wouldn't even
call Club rugby I would pretty much call
it I don't even know in terms of back to
New Zealand it yeah really frustrating
but he you know he got his Fitness did
his tackling match Fitness is you know
for rugby players know that's another
whole you know thing you've got to keep
up so he kept playing you know I had my
our second baby Camille um in November
and I literally had her he was Al also
sometimes at the 24th man for the top
team so he would try and go to a game
and then warm up and as you know then
sit on the stands and watch Mystics
Vibes oh yeah like you've got this I was
like I was like you're going you're
going because you never know there could
be in hamstring in the warm up and
you're playing like I was real like no
you're going and as much as it h much as
it was a struggle for him I was like cuz
that one shot I know it was going to
come and then I had um I was going into
um having my my second child and it was
a game in Po and he was the 24th man cuz
Zack Holmes was carrying a little
niggle and he went to PO which is 2hour
drive from here and I went into labor
and he's like oh I'll come back I was
like no no no no if Z it's not 100 you
need to stay there because you know you
might get on the field and so I thanks
to having KL Aon a b plyy boy and his
wife adoha who's Cy bra's sister-in-law
all Family Ties um ended up coming with
me to the hospital being my side my my
uh 4:00 she was born and boys were on
the bus to the game and she ran Carl and
Peter sitting beside each other on the
bus and here's your daughter Camille so
I gave him birth and he's driving to the
game um did the warm up and Zack played
the game Peter s in the St but the
manager drove him the manager drove him
straight home back to too and um and
didn't watch the match drove him
straight back and got him into the
hospital and then car walked up later
and we had beers and they were having
beers sorry in the hotel but then the
next day wakes up at 11:00 a.m. goes and
plays for isas on the Sunday all right
that's commitment eh like I was like
Peter get up where you go go play your
game he says I've had some beers in
Camille I I'm in the hospital can't go
anywhere in France you have to stay for
3 days so off you go and he went and
played the S game that afternoon like
just his mindset and then sure enough um
yeah I think it was November oh no
December um they had a clont away game
and all the boys were out like Ro Roman
andac was a 12 at the time for too so he
was Peter's position um Roman andac was
12 Tomy Ramos was 10 so he had a pretty
stacked Midfield in front of him and but
I you know just keep going keep going
and even Luke knowing with six nations
and how long that is for the boys and
yeah so he got a shot for clemont um the
game against clemont we actually drove
up there with um the girls watched I
said in the hotel where he played the
game with friends that were over and he
had an absolute Blinder um set up the
winning try with Max madad um and uh
then he was like starting every week and
then it was like oh well the French boys
are going to come back now uh going into
that New Year in
2019 and um yeah he was all of a sudden
the starting 12 still and then they
pushed ROMs to 10 kind of flicked him
across to 10 and 12 and um you know and
yeah his body was totally fine no
niggles shoulders knees everything was
fine he was just playing out of his skin
and um then fast forward to that June
they won the top 14 yeah crazy he what a
story hey I'd actually gone I'd actually
gone home
I got home cuz my for for family reasons
and um I remember sitting on what cuz my
n was sick and I went home and I missed
the obviously Luke has been here when
they've want it and the French would do
something else and he that for me seeing
him with my family in the necki um and
watching him win that game against um
clont and just him going back to the too
afterwards the parade through the town
the puss UPS everything just yeah was
for me massive on his first first year
after everything the first six months
treated like he was to then getting a
shot training hard and keeping at it and
then they won it and he's never looked
back and we're going into season six now
um and yeah he's won three so cool um
and one a European as well so I just
yeah the story for him um and that
obviously helps me and the helps me and
my obviously not being able to be at
home and do my follow my dream um but I
actually went back in 2020 so try to go
back in 2020 and go for the next cycle
and rang bunts and say look I love being
a mom I love being over here but I'm
really struggling I want to come back
and he said yep cool you need to come
back and play Nationals and then
December and then contracts January came
back flew back with my little girls by
myself um PA the Nationals got the
contract moved my moved pretty much over
to the Mount centralized with a family
friend my best friend's mom and dad and
love there uh January February March cuz
obviously Peter was established here now
he was comfortable he was training he
was in a good in a good um routine so I
thought I'm going back and he's like
where you go go give it a crack again
you want to go to you know get a gold
medal so I uh went back um TR my ass off
again got back on the team in the
environment the 20 contract the girls
and then Co hurt in March a 2020 of
course I was like uh what and I just
remember Deb Anderson who's the top dog
doctor um when it all kind of started
happening and the talks in that March
and obviously Peter was in France and
everything was kind of hitting really
quick over here and they were in
lockdowns and stuff was happening really
fast I'm like oh we're fine over here
and I remember her calling me being like
um we all got sent back home um for a
week toed till things settled down and
she rang me and was like Kayla I think
you need to get on a plane back to
France because I think the world's going
to shut down and there's going to be no
Olympics I was like no D you're laughing
you're having a laugh and she was like
uh no they I'm telling you now I talked
to the the government I'm in talks with
big dogs and I can tell you you know
friend to friend person to person
because she's she's awesome um you need
to go back be with your family because
the the world's going to go into
lockdown um and there's going to be no
Olympics and I was like okay so within
about 3 days got on a flight uh there
was the rer charge ones with like the
stuck French of citizens in New Zealand
got on their free flight and I may
actually get on a guitar flight with the
girls and I came back and France had
done a four- we lockdown and I got back
in the second week second lot of um the
four-week lockdown and it was probably
the best time of my life because me and
Peter and the girls were at home all day
every day it was summer we had my cousin
was living with us some of the boys are
living with us and it just life stopped
and you just looking back now it was
crazy but at that time I was this is
just what I needed just family time and
having Peter around and there's no
Olympics and then sure enough there was
no Olympics and I was like oh and then
it shifted to 21 and I was like it's
long it's s it's gone Kayla it's gone I
was like I can't um it's not going to
happen so I yeah stopped that dream and
obviously um just and obviously they
said it was going to be 2021 I said oh
it's just too far for me because bun is
like you need to be here from the first
of Jan um and for me to go through that
next year and then go back again I was
just like oh my kids this is too much so
turned that down um but happy is Larry
here because Peter's carving up enjoying
himself playing great great bunch of
boys around him just
an living his best life and for me
that's all you know that that makes
everything so much better and the girls
are happy here in school and I was happy
with all the the Wags and our
environment and and our City's pretty
cool and then I was actually back in New
Zealand when the Olympics happened uh
Tokio and I ended up jumping on um Sky
the sky TV with Linda aunu and
commentated the girls final um and yeah
I think when the when the whistle went
and they won the gold I was just like
like a I think n n um Williams was next
door at the channel one or another
Channel um at the time and she was
obviously she being rolled out from a
neck injury and she was like almost
there but missed out so she was you know
balling for her reasons and I was across
the other one balling like just but also
a sense of Pride for the girls CU you
know to get the golders you know some of
those girls with have been there two
cycles and it's
just yeah the [__] that the team had
gone through um UPS downs and and
political stuff and um working to see
them get the gold especially um sad for
me in terms of I wanted to be there but
I'm so happy they got that um and for
the nation and then the you know girls
aspiring to play rugby and it's a bigger
picture so yeah tough but awesome um and
I was obviously with Linder at the time
it was like it's KK uh but really um and
then yeah so but I guess for me being in
France and following Peter's rugby and
him doing so well has made it a lot
easier um yeah in terms of it all but
it's been a Juggle um obviously shereé
and Gillies are the other couple that I
you know crack up at and give each other
[__] and then got and then it gets worse
because then the World Series decided to
have two legs in to loose for two years
so I was like this is really salt in the
wound so again like proud would also
like I want to be on the field right now
and everyone would give me shirt so they
would come over and I would go to the
Jersey presentation and see all the
girls but really like miss you all I
just want to like that was um the first
year was like oh yeah cool cuz I I think
I was pregnant with Camille yeah I was
pregnant with sad the third one when
they came over I like oh you know I
can't jump on the field you know say
Andre all mocking me but then last year
they came and I um had Tyler uh shereé
and Stacy Walker come down and stay with
me for a couple of days on their day off
and yeah that was really hard because I
was like oh I'm fit I just want to jump
on with your girls and play and and it
wasn't until that um that tournament
Peter still gives me [__] I'm oh cook
and then the final and then they're
doing the hucker and the rain I like
start crying and I like I obviously had
a few Wines in the stadium and I'm like
like he's like what's wrong with you and
then Holly hook Elliot's wife like just
[__] leave here Peter she's having a
moment those are her sisters I'm like I
just want to be on the field I was like
[__] you Peter and he's like whoa whoa
whoa like he knows I've got a burning
desire but he's also I think he
understands that you know I've given a l
up to be here but it's still we're a
family and I'm here to support him and
he's he's a bread bread earner so it's a
no-brainer um but yeah it was last year
was that was tough having them here and
then also going to their trainings and
watching them and
and then them yeah being in the in the
crowd but from on the other on the
sidelines with my wine and the girls and
but then I took them out that night had
an awesome night in t with the men's and
women's team and and had a cool night
out with them which you know for Peter I
think not a lot of people know from the
sidelines you're put in an environment
with women people that you don't know
you're forced to be friends with them
forced to get along with them to an
extent they're not not not your people
but it's a different kind of a different
environment compared to when you're with
your ex you know your mates or your
sisters or your family so when they came
over that night I was remember saying
the P I like you're not drinking this is
my night these are my mates like you
drink with your boys every weekend and
get in on the purse and go out or
whatever I was like these are my friends
in town this is my night and he's like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and I was like
next minute all the other foreign boys
are coming and I'm like what is this is
this all of us like and all the girls
like it's all good and what David only
knew um the one of the props he's
American someone in place through
America his apartment is right in town
so we like pre- drinks at his apartment
after the girls you know after they
finished their Awards night and tus and
had pre- drinks there and then went to a
bar and like which one of J michan owns
Jew um the French hooker he owns a bar
and so it was really cool like just and
then all the other Wags are here like I
was just so nice seeing you with your
exg children like your people Kayla like
oh my God like I like I I didn't realize
it until that you SE it but I haven't
been so happy having them all here and
just being around you know girls I wish
I probably would still be with um Peter
was still playing in New Zealand um and
obviously that Moana when that came to
shape and we thought about coming back
in him and giving that another crack um
in the middle of our top 14 a couple
years ago but he's like um why would I
leave this club like the money's good
the I'm playing with the worlds the
French French Internationals um and
other Internationals I just didn't make
sense for us to shift back
for yeah for supers which is pretty
tough on the body as you know like it's
pretty pretty demanding
um this competition it's long it's 11
months long with two comps but I don't
think the ruges is is quick and fast and
physical as as Super Rugby and um in
that sense and the training back there
that those you know very professional
here it's a bit different
um so I don't know if Peter would be
just going from New Zealand from France
back to New Zealand after having a
having a stint of it here he's killing
credit to boys that go from France back
to New Zealand supers because it's a
different once you to take of the French
life and yeah it's not easy um so yeah
that was on the cards for a burden and
which mean I come back and play as well
and other Moana gig but it's um what was
best for our family and his rugby and
his body was was to be up here in France
so have you still got burning desires to
play it sounds like it oh yeah yeah yeah
no but I I've even had the president of
his team be like you know got to come
play for us I'm like I can't speak
French and then I'm like I've I've got a
kid I've got another kid and I just I
make excuses and find excuses but I
reckon if he was playing in England or
Ireland I'd probably still be playing oh
true um just the language barriers is a
big difference um and the support
network around and you know here I'd
have it but I don't want to rely on
other partners and wives to deal with my
kids you know like it's just not the
same um and then I in saying that the
games are all on Sundays when they
travel away and I would miss Peter and
that's for him it's me and the stands
and his daughters in the stands that you
know get them up and stuff so yeah I
have thought about it but I'm like if
there's a couple of sens tournaments
I've told them maybe maybe this year or
next summer but who knows but yeah um
I'm quite content where I'm at now
although you know it's not easy now I've
got three little madams to deal with I
am quite quite busy and this podcast of
mine that's with Jada quite busy yeah um
but yeah just seeing Peter Excel and and
him you know enjoying rugby again after
what was almost career ending and going
back to Club rugby um to see where he is
today is pretty special and his body
like yeah back he had multiple shoulders
shoulder sore knees and comes here and
he's fine yeah had a couple of cleanups
but what about your body how how much
harder is it each time post baby to come
back I had Taylor Johnson um Taylor and
M come across a couple weeks ago for the
World Cup because they had fomo she just
had a little boy and um medy junor and
bought him over and she's like I just
don't know how you even he's three
months and I couldn't even the thought
of even running even I said no you're
obviously I was pretty intense with st I
only put on like 10 kgs and I was next
level crazy um but no I I don't see it
as a problem that's another reason why I
and especially when CU girls Mock and
laugh was obviously di FIA funger come
back and had twins um she was in the
sevens and then had twins with Tony sh
and then went back and I think it was
like a mancher that if Kayla can go and
have a baby and come back any of us
can that was that was a thing for me cuz
I wasn't the Fest fastest strongest like
and so for me to have a baby and come
back it was it was even more drive for
me to be like you girls can like in a
year have a baby and come back come back
after 6 months like and also
internationally as well like some of the
Aussie girls that were doing it Alicia
Quirk Emily Cherry like they like oh it
can be done um so for me I was like it's
just yeah it's obviously some people
have horrific births and and whatnot but
um if if they it's all good I don't see
it as as a as a problem or a blockage or
a reason why you can't so a lot of girls
are on the stands now having babies and
coming back couple of girls on the
english team which is really cool to see
that I follow and and they're back in
there and being supportive from the
union which is um all I've ever wanted
to see which is really cool um and then
I Bob bumped into Rob nickel because
Peter obviously did the World Cup for
Tonga and bumped into him after the last
game and um I was like haven't seen you
since I left and he's laughing he's like
oh we had a few drinks each and said oh
well um when we come out to New Zealand
I might need a job he's like any day
Kayla like oh cuz I gave him a few
headaches when I was when I was there in
that environment um wasn't
all grass and and smelling flowers so he
was you know put to work a bit with me
but he's awesome so caught up with him
and um went through a few Memory Lane
with him about when I was back there and
and obviously now seeing him seeing
three of my daughters which he was just
like got three kids and Peter's playing
for Tonga like what what even as when I
left you were like didn't know what was
happening I said yeah no it's been six
years now so crazy so that was quite
quite cool and a um called bump into
home couple weeks ago or last month so
see how far we've actually come as a
couple of the family too so oh so cool
and you're obviously trailblazing in
terms of like um a woman athlete having
a baby and getting back to the sport and
something that like obviously us males
um definitely take for granted like the
prime years of your playing career uh
obviously your Prime baby producing
years as well so it's a it's a huge Comm
to be able to juggle that and you doing
that I'm sure so many different women
female athletes have got heaps out of
seeing you do it and true inspiration
hope so that's why I'm telling Tyler to
hurry up but she's she's still still
waiting for your baby
Tyler um but yeah it's been cool um and
it's not forever this journey I guess um
for Peter's career and any any career in
sport it's not forever so I know we'll
go home soon and back to semi- reality a
different reality for us so yeah living
it up over here as much as possible
missing our family every day which is
probably the hardest um especially for
me I don't have a a village we have a
little village you know we're quite
lucky in to if people know that the
foreign group here is really cool Joe
Joe and Helen Cory have just another
reason we've been so well looked after
here as they've always pushed for
foreign and French to kind of be
together and um obviously Charlie and
Michelle far were massive for us too so
we came in a really good time Jerome D
Charlie shs and Joe and Helen um so in
the last 5 years we've been pretty
pretty well looked after in terms of the
island culture and our you know Village
away from our big Village so I don't
think we would have got this experience
anywhere else so we've um literally hit
jpot coming to too where Luke was um
where my cousin is also here playing who
Lov you know my little girls love and
then obviously the the foreigners we
have here really really cool cool group
so very very lucky um but it's not
forever so um we are renegotiating right
now so who knows what right now we're in
that moment where I don't know what's
happening next year again yeah blood
twoe
cycle the twoe Cycle's happening right
now so I'm like um yeah don't know but
you know it is what it is I've learned
over the last couple of years to just
roll with it go with it since Co really
um and you know everything happens for a
reason so it's going with it and the
girls are good so yeah the way Peter's
going I'd imagine it be hard to see you
guys leaving there until he's fully done
like on fire don't know so I you know
the Market's pretty pretty strong over
here at the moment obviously with
English teams going under um as You'
know a lot of English boys are jumping
across here as well and so the market is
pretty tough um and when you hit over 30
in France they think you're old so um
Luke would know that and Cory and some
of the boys you know like yeah the age
thing is Big here I don't know why but
so yeah it's it's interesting times at
the moment which you know comes in every
two or 3 years um so we're in that now
but you know we're we're comfortable
whatever happens happens um he's
accomplished a lot being here in 5 years
and proved himself and his family and
and the people here um that were there
that first year um so no it's one
championships he's happy and yeah um but
it is at the end of the day a job that
is special uh the salary in terms of you
know making the most of it when you you
know as much as you can um but if we
come home I probably will be going into
a full-time job and I cannot wait to get
back to work which I know a lot of
people would never think we'd say but
I'm like I need to work so I'm I'm happy
I'm ready when it happens um but for you
boys it's another whole you know that
life after rugby is another whole
conversation um yeah pretty scary um
some for some boys and unknown but for
me I can't wait to get back into work
well you've got a job with the RPA
you're you're really to go yeah hey Rob
Rob got me a job um but yeah so but
obviously Peter it's an unknown area
that will be our next um when that when
that comes to it and obviously Charlie
and relle F have just finished up here
and kind of got some guidance from them
and watching what they you know their
transitional phase so yeah just it's
different for everyone so I don't know
um but that's what we're kind of we're
dealing with soon in the next couple of
years it's not now I don't know so oh
exciting times exciting times for the AK
family then what a journey what a
journey you guys have been on it's
incredible over the past six years or
even before that been um some Journey
but we have gone to the Instagram for
some questions so I'll quickly run
through a few of these um I know it's
late over there in France first one who
wins run it straight you or Peter run it
straight oh I I need a bit of movement
so he'll win because it's running it
straight I don't run it straight so
definitely Peter oneone no he runs it
straight I don't run it straight I I get
away I I go away from content he
actually runs it straight so
Peter would you be you'd be able to
stiff him though or may I have a couple
maybe yeah moments on the
five okay next one advice you'd give
young ladies to stay hungry um hungry
for food or hungry for like
rugby oh I just yeah um it's the
training the work ethic behind the
scenes that no one's watching for me if
I've learned anything um you know doing
the the little 1centers that people call
it now um eating right
training obviously the social scene for
is a different one but you know choosing
when and when not to um doesn't mean
getting on the piss every weekend but
choose your moments um but the not
sacrifice but more of a choice and a
different lifestyle but yeah just have a
goal write it down um work towards it um
and if you get knocked back in terms of
selection just keep going back don't
just give up and change something else
just keep going and yeah it'll it'll
happen but yeah it's the little 1 perent
is for me that wish I had I wish I had
done um you know 10 years ago go a
little bit better oh I like that that is
good advice for any young not just women
athletes but um any any athlete okay
next one how did her mindset SL Outlook
change towards sport once she hadd had
her first beautiful girl oh it's a whole
different reason for doing something so
I was like you have a purpose um that
Rel like I don't know I just yeah this
is a really this is like a feeling one I
can't even explain it um but when I went
back to my first tournament for Dubai my
whole outlook was different um who I was
playing for she was on the sideline um
sometimes I there be a some Chase
someone down for example and I'd be like
G you know let them score and we just
get back another try I would chase him
down because I'm just like so yeah it it
um gives you a lot more appreciation and
it's half of you like it's something
you've made um really hard to explain
until you experience it yourself but
gives you more
motivation um and yeah I did work a
little bit harder a lot harder um and
had to and I guess you have someone to
rely on you and you want to make someone
more prder I got my mom and dad and my
family and my husband but when it's a
child um you do everything to make sure
that when they look back or can look
back at you that you know you've made
them proud so sense of a bit of
responsibility but yeah it was a
different motivation to what I've
normally had Mission yeah yeah makes
sense like that okay next one who would
you often go to for advice obviously you
had a um few options with Peter Luke and
um the old man I will just tell a story
after you Charlie Mack for people that
know my dad is um yeah one of you know
he's obviously a coach a player a dad a
granddad but for me for four years and
now playing the sport that he's wanted
me a play since de do I would come off a
match off a game so this and also my mom
has her five cents too because she's
really supportive and Luke Luke knows
that too because Dad was really tough on
Luke and mom was always a positive one I
would come off games and I'd have a text
from Luke my dad and Peter Luke's one
would be like good good work good game L
see like awesome doing really well D
like you need to work on this this and
this and the next game and then Peters
was like a bit in between like you did
really well but just focus on that I had
three different angles and sometimes I
wouldn't even go to my phone after a
game I'd just be like then next block
for four hours I'm like I just know it
was coming um but then when I was on the
the struggling side of selection and Jes
um literally those three and my mom yeah
um yeah Mom Dad Peter and um mom for for
moral support but yeah was usually dead
because I I would I wouldn't hear what I
want to hear from my dad I'd hear what I
need to hear um Luke's a little bit more
cautious because he's obviously head dad
and knows what it's like the feeling of
being you know told some things and
obviously Peter tries to be liil so yeah
dead although we we butt heads and we
clash as people would know but usually
i' after a few hours I get over it but
yeah Dead all three angles how good that
you're getting you're getting all the
advice and you can pick and choose
depending on how you're feeling don't
wor about mom mom will give you her
advice too us your F do this do that I'm
like you know so Mom never and my mom as
well so she was you know and there was
she she is a sideline R yell like she's
just she knows just as much of the
gamers as probably the rest so my mom
too good stuff okay next one um did you
ever consider a sponsorship with M oh s
to Luke's M
boots well if the H was good then I'd
say yes but they made personalized boots
for Luke when he was there but uh no
when I was there I didn't get off of I
think in my era couple you know there
was not really individual sponsors it
kind of happened when as I left after
the individual sponsors were coming in
the nzu were more open to the girls
having individual sponsors and
conflicting sponsors um but when I was
there it wasn't really happening um and
if it was it wasn't really me unless it
B in big chunk of money um I wasn't I
was focused but no if maida came knock
now you know if they still
available take it never say no okay
there you go might have relaunched that
boot project um okay next one what is
the mallister quad routine what was the
McAllister quad routine growing up
nothing it was just genetics from my
granddad Charlie so my dad's my dad's
dad um my granddad has got Cals that
can't fit into gum boots and the
freezing works and the necki and um
yeah
I yeah I don't know I think Luke would
tell you the same it just as genetics um
for us um yeah I didn't do quad workouts
or in the gymer anything if that's what
they're asking but if anything probably
car phrases to help with you know ankles
and ankles but no it's a genetics from
my granddad Grandad Charlie who's still
alive today um down on the Nei um but
he's got lots of stories and one of them
is his Cal's not fitting in his work
boots so genetics man genetics what
people would do to get those genetics in
their quads and CS oh not even having to
lift and getting quads like that
incredible no shut up okay uh what are
the challenges unique to females in
sports other than dollars probably the
support obviously the the bums on seats
in in and stadiums um like big G talking
about sevens um 15s I'm probably
speaking more for the 15s game yeah um
for me seeing the Woman's World Cup I
actually had a group of French women
come to me and ask for advice going to
New Zealand to watch the World Cup and
follow the French girls and I literally
said I'm really sorry but I don't know
if the crowds are going to be any good I
just said look I'm telling you now um
going from the French crowd that has H
crowds at Club level yeah I basically
out of really embarrassing I kind of
said look you're not you know maybe in
between games going travel around New
Zealand which they did but I said look
you're not going to get much of crowds
and it's just woman's you know rugby and
just rugby in New Zealand at the moment
and a bit of a and wow I totally got put
on back shut down um the crowds were
unreal they came back and had the time
of their life um these French this
French family and two two women were
just like it was the best ever like and
the girls won it obviously the French
didn't but the Our Girls won it so for
me you know it's they're getting the top
top games and obviously the world 15's
coming now so they're making changes and
making it just those barriers trying to
be on par with the men's side which
never will be the same because it's you
know it's new and it's it's evolving but
more more games more tournaments um and
for sevens I mean sevens is pretty good
at the moment it's whe took Olympics com
games so they're going pretty well com
game yeah but for me it's a 15 side that
I want you know I've seen a big push in
the last five years um which is really
cool Contracting and new so it's a
pathway for girls not just Divens also
black ferns um so that's massive I came
back home recently this in June and
caught up with Carla and hoodie and
Alexa STS on just spoke about how you
know the game is growing and it is a
pathway now from yeah the 15s wasn't
really paid it was kind of like a half
half pie thing and it was [__]
frustrating because to be the best you
need to be able to train like the best
and they were having to hold down jobs
ande of all this you know I kind of knew
because we did the sevens and you just
can't do it it's just there's not enough
time in the day and you're not getting
your sleep you're not getting you know
your recovery so to see that game in the
15's change for our for the black ferns
was really special um they making
movements and the nzu coming to the
party and and Alan Bunting and and
obviously how winning the World Cups
made a massive change make make changes
so yeah it's more the big games big
tournaments and um the the structure
around back home they're being full-time
athletes like the men yeah now has been
awesome to see hey like that World Cup
was I think everyone was surprised with
the numbers like it was incredible and
New Zealand got right behind it and um
and the flying effect has been awesome
and now seeing becoming more and more
professional more and more full time
it's um so cool for the for the women's
game it's only going to grow the whole
game in in the overall scheme of things
okay last question best piece of advice
you have for a wad listener love
finishing with this and Jeep as you've
given some good stuff yeah you're full
of advice follow life from the sidelines
with Kayla and
Jayla um oh I don't even I just I think
since Co my whole outlooks changed and
just live every day um as it comes and
obviously with what's happening in the
world as well with with the war and and
all that as well it's just a terrif you
know it's crazy times um but just yeah
tell your loved ones you love them every
day um take every day as it comes which
is you know at the moment for my manure
and for Peter and our family and you
know the future who knows but um yeah
just love your family love the ones you
love and keep in contact with them and
ones who are in the sporting Avenue just
keep training hard on working hard um
but yeah for me family is everything so
um just telling my checking with loved
ones
and yeah best advice just live every day
that comes talk [__]
no if you made that up that is
incredible because that is powerful it's
I can feel all the emotion and it's
obviously how you live like um you've
had to bit go through a fair bit
throughout your career obviously um very
successful career yourself and then
having to you know juggle that with
supporting your husband and having
children and um all this uncertainty of
where you're going to live where you're
going to be what's next um it's not easy
but it's been so cool to hear how you've
managed to get through it all and how
you're so happy now over there and
seeing Peter do so well on the big stage
has been um awesome to see as well so um
really appreciate you coming on the
podcast and like you said make sure if
you are listening to this um go go
follow life on the sidelines and the
girls and the girls yeah you get more
girls on 100% that is that is the goal
but really appreciate you coming
on cool thanks Jam that was cool and um
have you done any more pranks late
lately because I didn't added in there
um your how I first knew who you were is
because you pranked Peter with p and to
this day it's still we show people on
YouTube um over here um and actually so
Jada as well see this guy actually I
don't know if I want to go on there cuz
he's going to prank me um but sheist was
like oh my God you I should have got you
with it
pedop fun memories of knowing who you
were the huran one of my favorites just
cuz he so like lowkey about it
but
huh best made I think it
was oh oh good times I appreciate you
coming on thank